how many alien civilizations are out
there do you think
well the universe is very big
so some
but
not as many as most people would like to
think is my view because the idea that
that there is a trajectory going from
simple simple cellular life like
bacteria all the way through to humans
it seems to me there's some big gaps
along that way the the eukaryotic cell
the the complex cell that we have is is
the biggest of them but also
photosynthesis is another the other
another interesting gap is a long gap
from
from the origin of the eukaryotic cell
to the first animals that was about a
billion years
uh maybe more than that
um a long delay in when oxygen began to
accumulate in the atmosphere so from the
first appearance of oxygen in the great
oxidation event to enough for animals to
respire
it was close to two billion years
um
why so long it seems to be planetary
factors it seems to be geology as much
as in anything else and we don't really
know
what was going on
so the idea that there's a kind of an
inevitable
march towards uh
complexity and and and um
sentient life i don't think he's right
doesn't not to say it's not going to
happen
but i think it's not going to happen
often
so if you think of earth given the
geological constraints and all that kind
of stuff
do you have a sense that life complex
life intelligent life happened really
quickly on earth over the day long
so
just just to get a sense of
are you more sort of saying that it's
very unlikely to get the kind of
conditions required to create humans
or is it even if you have the condition
it's just statistically difficult
i think the the i mean the problem the
single great problem at the center of
all of that to my mind is the origin of
the eukaryotic cell which happened once
and without eukaryotes nothing else
would have happened
and that is something that
that's because you're saying it's super
important the eukaryotes but i i'm
saying tantamount to saying that it is
impossible to build something as complex
as a human being from bacterial cells i
totally agree in some deep fundamental
way but it's just like a one cell going
inside another
is not so difficult to get to work right
like
well again it happened once
um and
if you think about if you if you think
i mean i'm in a minority view in this
position most biologists probably
wouldn't agree with me anyway but if you
think about the the starting point we've
we've got a simple cell it's an archaeal
cell we can be fairly sure about that so
it looks a lot like a bacterium uh but
is in fact from this other other domain
of life so it looks a lot like a
bacterial cell that means it doesn't
have anything it doesn't have a nucleus
it doesn't really have
complex endo membrane it has it has a
little bit of stuff but not not that
much
and it takes up an endless inbound
so what happens
next
and the answer is basically everything
to do with complexity
to me there's a beautiful paradox here
um
plants and animals and fungi
all have exactly the same type of cell
but they all have really different ways
of living so a plant cell
is photosynthetic
they started out as algae in the oceans
and so on so think of algal blooms
single cell things you know the the
basic
uh
the basic cell structure that it's built
from is exactly the same with a couple
of small differences is got chloroplasts
as well it's got a vacuole it's got a
cell wall but that's about it and pretty
much everything else is exactly the same
in a plant cell in an animal cell
and yet the ways of life are completely
different so this these this cell
structure did not evolve in response to
different ways of life different
environments i'm in the ocean doing
photosynthesis i'm on land running
around as part of an animal uh i'm a
fungus in a soil uh
spreading out long kind of shoots into
whatever it may be
mycelium so
they all have the same underlying cell
structure why
almost certainly it was driven by
adaptation to the internal environment
to having these pesky endosymbionts that
forced all kinds of change on on the
host cell now in one way you could see
that as a really good thing because it
may be that there's some inevitability
to this process as soon as you've got
endless imbalance you're more or less
bound to go in that direction or it
could be that there's a huge fluke about
it and it's almost certain to go wrong
in just about every case possible that
the conflict will lead to effectively
war leading to death and extinction
and it simply doesn't work out so maybe
it happened millions of times and it
went wrong every time or maybe it only
happened once
and it worked out because it was
inevitable and actually we simply do not
know enough now to say which of those
two possibilities is true but both of
them are a bit grim
but you're
you're leaning towards
we just got really lucky in that one
leap
like we got so do you have a sense that
our galaxy for example has just
maybe millions of planets with bacteria
living on it i would expect billions
tens of billions of planets with
bacteria living on it practically i
would i would i mean there's probably
what five to ten planets per star
of which i would hope that at least one
would have bacteria on
so i expect bacteria to be very common
uh i i simply can't put a number
otherwise i mean i expect it will happen
elsewhere it's not that i think we're
living in a completely empty universe
that's so fascinating but i think that
it's not going to happen inevitably and
there's something you know it wasn't
that's not the only problem with uh with
with complex life on earth i mentioned
knox and animals and so on as well and
even humans we came along very late you
go back five million years and you know
would be that impressed if we came
across a planet full of giraffes
i mean you'd think hey there's life here
there's a nice planet to colonize or
something we wouldn't think oh let's try
and have a conversation with this
giraffe
yeah i'm not sure what exactly we would
think
i'm not exactly sure what makes humans
so interesting from an alien perspective
or how they would notice i'll talk to
you about cities too because that's an
interesting perspective of uh how to
look at human civilization
but your sense i mean of course you
don't know but it's an interesting
world it's an interesting galaxy it's an
interesting universe to live in that's
just like
every sun
like 90
of uh
solar systems
have bacteria in it
like imagine that world
and
the galaxy maybe has
just a handful if not one
intelligent civilization
that's a wild world and so wow i didn't
even even think about that world there's
a kind of
thought that
like one of the reasons it would be so
exciting to find life on mars or titan
or whatever
is like if its life is elsewhere then
surely
statistically
that life no matter how unlikely you
curious multicell organisms
sex
uh violence
what else is extremely difficult i mean
uh photosynthesis
is figuring out some machinery that
involves the chemistry and the
environment to allow the building up of
complex organisms surely that would
arise
but man i don't know how i would feel
about just bacteria everywhere well it
would be depressing if it was true
i suppose
i don't think natural i don't know
what's more depressing bacteria
everywhere nothing everywhere
yes either of them are chilling yeah but
whether it's chilling or not i don't
think should
force us to change our view about
whether it's real or not
and what i'm saying may or may not be
true so how would you feel if we
discovered life on mars
absolutely it sounds like you would be
less excited than some others
because you're like well what i would be
most interested in is how similar to
life on earth it would be it would
actually turn into quite a subtle
problem because
the
the likelihood of life having gone to
and fro between between mars and the
earth is
is quite i wouldn't say high but it's
not low it's quite feasible
and so if we found life on mars and it
had
very similar genetic code but it was
slightly different
most people would interpret that
immediately as evidence that they've
been transit one way or the other and
that it was a it was a common origin of
life on mars or on the earth and it went
one way the other way the other way to
see that question though would be to say
well actually though the beginnings of
life lie in deterministic chemistry and
thermodynamics starting with the most
likely abundant materials co2 and water
and a wet rocky planet and mars was wet
and rocky at the beginning
and will i won't say inevitably but
potentially almost inevitably come up
with a genetic code which is not very
far away from the genetic code that we
already have
so we see subtle differences in the
genetic code what does it mean it could
be very difficult to interpret is it
possible do you think to tell the
difference or something that truly
originated
i i think if the stereochemistry was
different
we have sugars for example that are the
l form or the d form and and um we have
uh d sugars and l amino acids right
across all of life but lipids
uh we have the bacteria have one one
stereoisomer and the bacteria have the
other the opposite stereoisomer
so it's perfectly possible to use one or
the other one
uh and the same would almost certainly
go for i think george church
has been trying to make life based on
the opposite stereoisomer
so it's perfectly possible to do and it
will work um
and if we were to find life on mars that
was using the opposite stereoisomer that
would be unequivocal evidence that life
had started independently there so
hopefully
the life we find will be on titan and
europa or something like that where it's
less likely that we shared and it's
harsher conditions so there's gonna be
weirder kind of life
i wouldn't count on that because
life started in deep sea hydrothermal
vents it's harsh that's pretty harsh
yeah so titan is different europa is
probably quite similar to earth in the
sense that we're dealing with an ocean
it's an acidic ocean there um as the
early earth would have been and it
almost certainly has hydrothermal
systems same with enceladus we can tell
that from these plumes coming from the
surface through the ice we know there's
a liquid ocean and we we can tell
roughly what the chemistry is
for titan we're dealing with liquid
methane and things like that so that
would really if there really is life
there it would really have to be very
very different to anything
that we know on earth
you